stillgelegte fabriken ausgediente bunker
verlassen der worte für die einen sind
es schandflecke doch für immer mehr
menschen sind es vor allem faszinierende
fotomotive
sie bezeichnen sich auch als erben
explorer also organe entdecker der
deutsche fotograf und journalist arno
specht erkundet solche verlassenen ortes
seit jahren seine kamera hat er immer
dabei eine gewisse faszination fürs
mobile oder für außergewöhnliche rote
rausch immer vorhanden zu den sozial
zündung war kein zufall
vor einigen jahren hat mein sohn mal im
netz bilder von den alten babys entdeckt
und das hat mich dann positive die
faszination auf einmal zu sehen das
ganze orte ganze relativ große komplexe
gibt die am stück sich selbst überlassen
sind verlassen sind ihre eigene ästhetik
entwickelt seit 2007 erforscht arno
specht vor allem die ostdeutschen
bundesländer dokumentiert leerstehende
gebäude und deren geschichte er ist
fasziniert von der ästhetik des verfalls
mittlerweile hat er 4 bildbände
veröffentlicht über berlin leipzig
dresden und mecklenburg vorpommern
gegenpol zu einer welt thema durch
geplanter inszenierter gestylte auch
wird ja wenn ich jetzt hier im raum
einkommen hier ist nichts geplant jetzt
nicht aufbereitet hier ist eigentlich
alles mehr oder weniger ein
zufallsprodukt da muss sich die pflanzen
an schaut dir erleben irgendwo gewachsen
im laufe der zeit oder der putz dir nach
irgendwelchen naturgesetzen runter
bröselt an manchen stellen hebt manchen
fällt darunter eigene kunstwerke schafft
eine eigene ästhetik wo aber kein mensch
dahinter steckt sondern einfach nur
entstehen aber ein gebäude jetzt über 20
30 jahre sich unter natur- und wetter
überlässt
in den vergangenen jahren sind
zahlreiche foto bildbände dieser art auf
dem buchmarkt erschienen
auch im netz fand sich das phänomen
schnell verbreitet zahlreiche blogs
widmen sich dem thema urban exploration
auf social media-plattformen wie
instagram oder facebook wächst die
community stetig der boom ist neu die
bewegung aber nicht vor gut 25 jahren
hat sich mit dem fall der mauer gerade
in der ehemaligen ddr ein neues feld für
irgend explorer eröffnet im system
verschwindet und mit dem system
verschwinden auch bestimmte aufgaben
bestimmte institutionen bestimmte
einrichtungen natürlich ganze
wirtschaftseinheiten sind aufgelöst
worden abgewickelt worden
es war auf einen schlag in diesen
umbruch da der ja schon verursacht
die bewegung hat ihre wurzeln in den usa
der industrielle niedergang in städten
wie detroit führte ab den 1950 er jahren
zum verfall ganzer stadtviertel die zum
spielplatz für kreative wurden ähnliche
entwicklungen gab es auch in anderen
ländern eine immobilienkrise in den 1980
er jahren tritt in japan wie exploration
bewegung los die dort ein kilo genannt
wird
auf das mittlerweile große interesse in
europa hat auch die firma good humor
reagiert
in und um berlin bietet sie spezielle
touren an bei denen man leer stehende
gebäude legal besichtigen und
fotografieren kann exploration ohne
risiko eine der beliebtesten touren das
haus der offiziere in wünsdorf rund
anderthalb stunden von berlin entfernt
auf dem gelände wohnten im kalten krieg
bis zu 60.000 sowjetische soldaten
1994 zog die armee ab seitdem steht das
gebäude leer parnass thiemann ist
tourleiter bykow anbieten können man
kann nicht zu viele leute auf die orte
nehmen das halten die orte nicht auf aus
wir gehen ja auch respektvoll mit den
orten um also sprich wenn wir da zweimal
touren machen mit 500 leuten wenn es der
ort so hinüber dass da nie wieder eine
tour machen kann und darum versuchen wir
im grunde mit kleinen grüppchen und aber
dafür gehäuft zu touren anzubieten
heute haben sich 18 teilnehmer
angemeldet
für 50 euro können sie das objekt in
ruhe erforschen
viele von ihnen sind hobbyfotografen die
faszination dass diese orte ja mal
irgendwann eine nutzung hatten die man
auch noch an oder oder bisschen spüren
kann
die ruhe motive die man sonst nicht
sieht auch wo man hinkommt als sehr
spannend
ich wollte zehn und ich fotografiert
dann ganz nett dass ein paar ausbilder
hat ich bin kein profi fotograf ich
knips hier noch exploration hat sich zu
einer weltweiten bewegung entwickelt an
schlecht glaubt dass dieser boom noch
eine weile anhalten wird